speaking of really good yeah an
entertaining stuff you know we're
talking about this new show coming to
the channel and no one will tell me
anything about it but I do want to hear
about it's a little it's a little on the
edge and I don't know it's a bit extreme
okay and I don't know if it's the wisest
move I don't know if talk this edge he
may get us in trouble you know that's
kind of you know I talked to some of the
bosses they were like Sam what do you
think of this I said I don't know it's
it's a risk if it works it's gonna work
big but you know we live in a very
sensitive time so you're due opinions
that are this sort of out of the box in
extreme may not be accepted as well as
we hope they are okay but let's hear I
want to hear I'm anxious I've been
waiting all weekend yeah they put
together a promo I had a lot more time
on Friday than I planned to think about
this oh I'll be asking you about that
let me talk about let's see what
happened let's hear the show from the
bench and crazy minds they give you
fashion
I've seen one time this person on a
train that just sat there she seemed
kind of crazy and she's just mouthing me
off for no reason that's right we're
just crazy enough to give Daniel Bobo
Kerlin his very own talk show
and I don't recall she's ever seen me
hear all about details hardcore life
when he's not over here I actually feel
bad when these people get their their
cars get stuck in the snow
I hope take their cars down we can't put
up at this job I have to help but dig
deep my sister's car out of the snow
Daniel Bobo girl and is coming to settle
we are the old same calm before the
storm warning this show is not over
children noodle a poodle have schnauzer
Oh
[Music]
exciting show coming to the channel soon
yeah it's real rock and roll that show I
couldn't believe when I started getting
tweets from people I really just ran out
of time because uh because we had Brooke
Shields on for so long it's like so much
stuff was going on on Friday that we
didn't have time to play it but I always
felt bad the people are actually
messaging me going wow this is [ __ ]
horseshit jason Ellis should not have
this kind of control jason Ellis should
not be putting new shows on it's like
dude relax
yeah it's a promo for Bobo's show yeah I
didn't even know what it was it's hoping
it wasn't that but it's extreme huh yeah
man what's a crazy channel you got some
extreme stuff some big changes ah it's
great